Ah, Woori Bank, did you grow when you saw the minis? The number of lights 0
5 What is a
jumper?
Mija means me split 3
then spay main rio 2 drm free a
flat twin cancer 842 er
[clap]
ah not empty 9 8 8
ah ah er ah
[clap] uh uh [clap]
cut off ah but dang  2 The
name of the category has been changed and
it is salty.
I couldn't do it 4 reasons why I couldn't
The wonderful actor and all the staff are here.
Our beloved Song Kang-nim, Lee Seon-kyun, the poet's atrium, the soul, the applause Dam,
Lee Jung-eun, the great actors and the fisherman's column.
1 Production Designer This very
common editor, Yangji, I give my thanks to Wonderbra and all of our artists.
Kka neat, in the meantime, over sch, Nai, and
Barunson and CJ, who made my vision come true, and no, thank you to everyone today.
Napa ridge cg animation Which you're heart ios words
Closed
[clap]
Ah, do you
want to drink?